i'm so excited to be here yeah fantastic
you know we are really truly great great
friends
we are and we we share so many things
we're both irish yes
catholic morning drinkers you know
you look fantastic well thank you very
much martin it's very nice you look like
someone freeze-dried prince harry
because there's a lot of pressure i
would take that i would take that right
now you know you're looking because
listen there's a lot of pressure to stay
looking good
as you know how does it feel to have
buckled i just did no
no you look you look great those
freckles are benign right yeah
no you're pale you are pale you have to
you look like the human embodiment of
utah you know
you worked for me what are you doing
like like something that would appear
the the baseboard of ebenezer scrooge's
bed
no you look fantastic and i'm excited to
be here at eight
let more shows you know and who's your
final guest i'm assuming it's jay leno
what did i do
[Applause]
i keep calling him and uh he won't come
he doesn't answer
someone's always like he's not here
right now
yeah yeah no really congrats 28 years
yeah
28 years or as matt gates would call it
11 years too old i don't know
what oh no i mean yes and i'm assuming
you're gonna go along grow a long beard
like letterman
you're the tallest member of zz you know
i
i was thinking about all the people that
i would most want to have
as we sort of wrap things up here in the
nightly format your name came to mind
and i kept thinking of others but
uh they weren't available but i
but uh but no uh mr martin short
there's no one uh who uh i i can think
of who means more to me
uh in the world of comedy you are the
consummate professional
and i we've become good friends and i'm
so grateful that you could be here we've
had some good memories
you've made some incredible appearances
on my show
this is this is my 26th appearance with
you
is that true yes starting back to the
old nbc yeah
26 two of them i walked through but four
i was gonna say
four were pretty good uh
[Laughter]
what do what sticks out does anything
stick out to you i mean you've done you
do so many shows
i remember oh i think okay all right
this is hilarious
so this was uh the old show on nbc yep
not the second one the old one
and um
why why i'm just trying to get out the
door with a little dignity
and i bring this leprechaun on
[Laughter]
to to throw
feces at me this was hilarious so
i i had been the first guest out and you
know kind of killed
and then i moved i moved down the couch
and then a young
actress came out i remember this but she
was like a model
that would had a part not a big part in
a tv movie yeah
but you know that was the guest you were
interviewing so you you know
were and i but i could see you like this
and you were here you were there
and and you're the way it's angled you
remember this andy that that so the
the first guest is i mean the the second
guest comes out
marty moves down she's right here she's
talking to me so
no one else can see what i see but i see
this face
and i'm looking at her and i'm doing the
best i can to be professional
what you said to her was so um most of
your career
now have you've been a model but now
you have a smaller part in a tv movie
was it was it challenging learning lines
and i go like this
he did that so she's
he does that she's all right so she
starts
she's really going to answer that
question
it's 1 20 in the morning
this is my job and and then suddenly i
see this
head peer out and go
and i start to laugh and i bite down
on both sides of my face just to get
through it it was hysterical and then at
a commercial break
conan gets up bands playing band's
playing he just walks over to me and
says
i'm just trying to make a living
[Laughter]
it was so funny you did something
and i swear to god you sent this to me
the other day
and what happens is if you do we've done
thousands of hours of this show
and you forget things and
you sent me a video clip and i looked at
it and i had
no memory of it whatsoever but
and i i it just blew my mind it's a time
you came on the show
and uh you showed a clip where you were
made up to look like me
with the great andrea martin it was a
sketch from primetime glick and i was
playing
you yeah uh i can't remember the name
you sent it to me
and imagine you have no idea you're just
living your life
your phone dings i push a video
this is what i see
[Applause]
all right so now i'm like this big goofy
hairy guy
i had no memory of that and then
yeah i texted you back and said i have
this is scaring me i may have cause i
you'd think i'd remember that forever
i have no memory of this and then
immediately you got another text
i sent it to andrea too you sent it to
andrea martin and she wrote back she
said i don't have
one memory is this from sc tv
i said when we were in sctv conan was in
the ninth grade yeah
it was an all-girls school